[Music]
thank you
[Music]
here we go
all right cheers Kevin cheers
good to see you clink clink so where are
we and what are we drinking are you
supposed to say welcome to the show and
[ __ ] you're already hammered
I'm not already hammered I just feel
like in my current state of mind and
Affairs of skipping the Preamble
skipping all the foreplay going straight
in you know if my audience if my
audience has been with me for 700 of
these I'm like you know you guys are
probably pretty limbered up by now
that's limbered
up love it yeah welcome to the Tim
Ferriss show everybody this is a special
edition random show
it's been a few months at least I know
it's good to see you we're we're
actually next to each other I know if
you're watching the video we are sitting
next to each other on my floor
which is is crazy yeah this is old
school I like it yeah
in front of a recording couch does my
audio sound weird to you listen to this
sounds weird to you test one two three
hello hello how's it going does that
sound weird
watch
see talk talk talk talk talk talk talk
talk you sound good right doesn't sound
weird you don't you don't sound weird
okay actually yeah you know when I get
close you're pretty close yeah
if I talk right now I'm getting a huge
gain blowback on my voice but not yours
oh interesting so maybe it's just uh
like a headphone thing yeah all right
sorry people we're gonna leave all that
in
that's actually pretty funny
people would be like what the [ __ ] are
these guys doing all right I'm investing
in Tequila folks not in editing I'm just
kidding half all right so so we are
actually in my new apartment in Los
Angeles
we're sitting on the floor in front of a
little table here
yeah I'm in La now I moved why did you
move to LA so you know
a lot of things going on because since
covet everybody from La has moved to
Austin is that true I mean a lot of a
lot of people have moved I know a lot of
people moved to Austin you know it was
one of those things where I was in
Portland Oregon for a few years loved it
beautiful beautiful place rains a lot
not a lot of friends yeah and so it was
hard because we're in the middle of
nowhere and you know it's it's actually
just kind of depressing like rain and no
friends
now when you moved there I have to say I
was like who does Kevin know in that
area yeah I I knew a couple people and
one of them moved and I had a couple
other friends and then one of them had a
baby
and you know with covert and everything
like you don't give them a new baby and
all that stuff so right it was tough
but my family was out there my mom's out
there you know my sister's uh still out
there and just decided hey let's get
away from them
honestly with all the nft stuff going on
and the majority of my calls were either
LA or New York that I was having work
wise yeah and so why not get down to
where everything is happening and so the
choice you know we weren't going to go
to New York because it's just winter
time New York you've already done New
York also and I have two kids and it's
like New York's harder with kids but
yeah so L.A why is New York harder with
kids
I mean when the snow is like the winters
the winters and you know it's
there's also traffic like I remember
when I was out in New York and I was
watching I'm just laughing because I
just spent three hours in traffic
driving from San Diego to Los Angeles
it's [ __ ] terrible there's a
difference between like La stop and go
freeway traffic and like you're watching
these kids and I saw this happen where
they make them all hold hands when
they're crossing the street of course
yeah and then like a taxi comes flying
around you know at a million miles an
hour it almost like wipes out a a I'm
just I just kind of freak out yeah when
we have the dad hat on with the kids I'm
like I don't want to have to worry about
that stuff right got it and so this is I
and I know there's more neighborhoody
stuff and there's there's areas of New
York where we definitely could have made
it work but
I don't know West Coast I'm still my mom
you know she's up there she's in her 80s
she's undergoing Cancer Treatments I
want to be on this Coast I can bounce up
in a second if I need to so you know
made sense that makes sense yeah
all right
so sitting on the floor
with a
beverage
that's a great question because this is
something of yours I am keeping it
simple and having some tequila
missing a little bit of Texas perhaps
dos artes hundred percent Agave Blanco I
wanted something that would maybe be
less likely to donkey punch me in the
head
hangover wise and so I chose this as
much for the blanco as for the bottle
itself I mean the actual ceramic
container is gorgeous this is one of our
our favorite Tequilas I gotta say a big
thank you to Anish
who introduced me to this tequila bought
me a bottle of this
as I think birthday gift or something it
just blew my mind so really good not not
crazy expensive I like middle of the
road kind of world but just awesome
together yeah I have no idea just for
the bottle alone I'm imagining this
costs a fair amount to make just true
for a lot of the premium alcohols like
you're paying
20 of the price or thirty percent of the
price for the glass or the crystal or
whatever you're actually not keeping
most likely so what are you drinking I
am having a little bit of champagne uh
just because my wife bought a bottle and
we opened it
um I am drinking a really douchey
champagne it's it's not douchey but it's
like it's kind of you say that on your
podcast you can say whatever you want
okay so it's um this is the funny thing
Dory came back from from the champagne
store which grocery store and she she
was like I I saved 300 and I'm like cool
what'd you get we don't ever drink this
champagne but there was apparently a
sale on something called Ace of Spades
which is Jay-Z's champagne it's actually
quite good it's actually quite good so
I'm just laughing because as soon as you
mentioned that before we were recording
and I was like and you also have a red
wine with Snoop Dogg's face on it that's
your sink I'm like
Tupac uh you know grass-fed butter
what's that what's coming so they're not
too far away from us is a grocery store
that basically has Snoop Dogg's wine and
is that kind of like a table wine and
and Dario needs it for cooking so she
bought Snoop Dogg it was like a six it
was like well I think 10 bottle of wine
don't judge the cost of Snoop Dogg's
table one I just thought I thought they
were gonna be there was going to be more
to that pattern that's it basically
and how is it um
it's quite good very dry
um fantastic so Cheers Cheers good to
see you man yeah it's been a long time
since we've done one of these in person
I know it reminds me of the old school
episodes that we used to do these all
the time in San Francisco yeah and even
with the glass background it makes me
think of one of your places in San
Francisco totally where all those people
showed up angry though the protesters
the protesters yeah that place that that
particular place if you didn't protested
yet
not been protested yet yeah well I think
that's gonna happen actually with your
higher thing you're working on oh God
I'm not sure
people's imaginations are like go wild
with what horrible thing I'm concocting
but I have not been protested I'll take
the Counterpoint and this is I don't
want to give him credit because I don't
know if he would want it but a friend of
mine
who has this Theory and I tend to agree
with it that people are going to be
10 percent less famous every year
if they're already a public figure
if they're not in Rapid Ascension if
they're not exploding and even if they
are if we go over a longer time frame
like it's one thing to be popular in
Tick Tock for a month
you're on Tick Tock right I'm not it's
quite a different thing to be popular
for like 10 years on 20 years yeah and I
just think that is going to become
harder and harder to do because it'll be
more of a pool of people that'll be oh
yeah yeah I mean the Internet is just I
mean just the young kids coming up on
you yeah I'm okay with it I'm tired are
you done I think I'm like that NHL
player where they're like oh wow yeah no
God given how many injuries he's had
he's doing pretty well out there limping
along on the ice yeah but let me let me
ask you the lesson he's giving it a good
college try I don't want to be there
have another particular because I have a
serious question to ask you here
tell me that was a really intense sip on
the microphone
that's why I don't wear a headset I
don't have to worry about it's very
intense Okay so
you don't want to go for Rogan you want
to take him out like you could you could
you could go for it no he's one easy one
oh for sure he's won yeah no that
doesn't even enter my mind really does
not even you have to have like a live
studio and [ __ ] because because a lot of
it has to do with that like life oh for
sure I mean he is a he's a television
professional I mean he's very good
interviewery is very good commentator
he's very comfortable in front of a
camera and is an excellent Storyteller
yes he's got to be five to ten times
bigger than his
runner-up in terms for interview format
podcast you got to be up there I'm up
there I mean I'm up there but
you have to understand that there's
there's Rogan and then there's like if
it were the Tour de France there'd be
like one guy
10 miles ahead yeah and then there'd be
a pack of he's like the guy on roid's
been there before no I don't mean he's
on Roy's I mean like in terms of his is
like how far ahead he is
yes I mean it's it's as if you then have
a cohort of folks there are like four or
five maybe who are like spread out over
200 yards and so there is maybe a
popularity sequence to it but they're 10
miles behind yeah the person in in first
place so I don't even I don't think
about
uh competing at all in that sense the
other thing though too is like I feel
like his content he's really good that's
writing the spicy [ __ ] on right I can't
really have the spicy guest on he knows
how to push the buttons and I feel like
you have kind of like not I mean you you
have like fantastic intellectual
conversations but I don't know that you
pushed the the agenda of like
normal celebrity for the sake of like
stirring up the Pod a bit you know yeah
no I don't I don't have the endurance
for it and he he's he really enjoys so
many different formats he
he is Joe Rogan meaning Joe Rogan is the
best version of Joe Rogan and I think
anyone who looks at what Joe does and
says I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do that
better and I'm gonna be bigger is
foolish I think that's a terrible idea
yeah no [ __ ] and Joe has
tremendous endurance I think in part
because he has
chosen formats and ways of communicating
and ways of presenting visually that it
seems he really enjoys yeah right so if
somebody tries to force fit themselves
into that game oh yeah they're gonna
lose yeah you both had Zuckerberg on the
show you maybe three months before him
four months something like that
behind the scenes how much prepping do
they give you of like don't ask Mark
this like what's that like they
they meaning his team
were extremely easy to deal with
for me did they say like this question
is off off limits like don't ask Market
that is they didn't I gave them as I
give every guest Final Cut so there
wasn't a lot of talk about prohibited
topics or anything like that and
did you go easy on him
I would say I went easy
there's something that people should
know if they don't already about the
show and deliberate decisions that that
I make so that I enjoy the format in the
same way that I think Joe does it with
his format
and anyone who has I think tremendous in
podcast years longevity which would be
at least five or ten
finds the format that they're best at
it's just like different shaped athletes
and different sports yeah
and
in the case of my podcast I made the
decision really early on
I don't want to have a gotcha show there
are many other people who are going to
do that better than I will because they
enjoy it I don't
I don't want to be Mike Wallace
even though this famous interviewer
if you have not heard that name you
should actually look him up because he
was a very skilled interviewer there's a
documentary about him that is fantastic
and has chilling footage of him and the
entire story behind interviewing the
Ayatollah Khomeini in any case
it's not hard ball
it's not any of these formats and
in part that this is gonna sound so
cheesy and Hallmark card but
I hated going into interviews myself
because you've been interviewed a ton
I've been interviewed hundreds or
thousands of times at this point and
when you go in and someone just cuts an
angle and is out to get some type of
headline that they're going to cherry
pick from a longer statement you make
and twist it out of context I just
didn't want anything to do with that I
wanted my show to be the show not
because it's easy necessarily
but because it's well researched and
thoughtful
and not out to be aggressive for the
sake of being aggressive
for all of those reasons and more there
were certain topics that I didn't bring
up
and in part that is because if it is a
topic let's just say I were to ask
Zuckerberg something like
what is your stance on a b and c or what
how do you personally think about
Russia Ukraine this that and the other
thing when that is a clear and present
high priority
area Focus within meta Facebook itself
he's not going to have any maneuvering
ability you know what I mean he's he's
going to feel as he should compelled to
give whatever response they have jointly
oh that shouldn't be the right response
and so for me to throw that out it's a
waste of everyone's time and oxygen
because number one We're not gonna get
and I wouldn't expect nor would I even
recommend that he give something new
and my podcast isn't live again for many
reasons
but
I think I know which trees are worth
barking up and which are not I think I'm
very good at picking those shots and if
people want let's just say a politically
oriented show or a controversy focused
show or true crime or something
there are tens of thousands of podcasts
brand new ones that come out every week
you can find something you enjoy for me
I wanted a lot of that interview you say
with Mark
which I was quite happy with
will remain Evergreen for a very long
time right so talking about
how he structures his life thinks about
priorities
how he integrates say belief systems
like religion into his family I mean
these are all questions that may not be
the topic of the week but that
nonetheless I think will preserve value
maybe even appreciate in value over time
as more and more people chase yeah
whatever happens to be trending that
instant well that's a great Point Tick
Tock yeah or whatever the platform is
remember Vine I mean yeah Risky Business
betting on one platform when I
interviewed Elon probably 10 years or so
ago
I I did the same type of approach where
it was very like let's get into who you
are as a person versus the topic of the
day and if you go back and watch that
interview today there's still some great
Evergreen pieces of content that are
like lessons from just his childhood
growing up like things that lessons that
he learned along the way the idea of um
taking things back to First principles
like the all that stuff was pretty new
when he talked about it back then yeah
and it was um I'm still really proud of
that interview that it's still you know
it still gets a lot of views and people
should turn ads on that [ __ ] I don't
have ads on that I can make a little
cash on the side that's you know I was
gonna say Kevin you know I saw you this
the holes in your socks yeah it's just
you know just breaking down all the
hand-me-downs that you're wearing times
are tough and the rose [ __ ] it's so
tough
foreign
honestly yeah because I love you I want
you to move to Los Angeles and have a
live show because I think a live show
would be because here's the question
like
I guess what I was trying to hint at
with the Joe Rogan piece is that I
believe
when I watch Zuck on his show and I
watch a lot of people Aaron Rodgers and
a few people that I've watched recently
the reason why he can get them to share
intimate details is because of that I
mean Aaron Rodgers is sitting there
smoking a cigar on his set right and
they're just kind of chilling out like
having fun it's the Elon moment with the
weed cigarette you know all that [ __ ]
but like that that magic can't happen
remote you know yeah it's a lot harder
it's a lot harder so I don't know I mean
I I would if
if you if you're gonna go for it like
I'd love for you to move to LA do but
that's just me personally you haven't
wanted to have you more my Orbit and
hanging out more often you know
you know I've thought about doing a
limited edition live series I was
actually looking at it right before
covet hit well you did that series that
television yeah Fearless yeah and I
enjoyed that and I would do it again and
there is a magic
a connection also an audio visual
component if you want to show
photographs or video sure that is very
hard if not impossible to replicate I
also just like having I think having an
audience is a lot of fun well think
about what Oprah it's like being an
athlete and having to compete it's going
from training to competing yeah and
since I don't do live very often I get a
cheap thrill out of it yeah but what
were you saying about Oprah well I was
just saying that she was able to break
down I mean a lot of the intimate stuff
that came out was because they were
sitting across from each other right you
felt like you were just with her during
that moment why don't you do six months
out of the year out here a little Studio
a little series it could be cool
actually maybe one month but the fact of
the matter is I moved to Austin because
I wanted to leave a scene I mean there
are tons of reasons but I remember you
were an SF right yeah and I was kind of
getting burnt out I was done for a
couple of years before I left and
then I got there and then covet happened
and what I thought was going to take
like five to eight years happened in 18
months and now Austin is a scene and
it's like [ __ ] well because I remember
one time I talked to you and I don't
know if you want to keep this in or not
but like there's one time where you're
like you moved to Austin kind of hoping
to kind of like get away from that [ __ ]
yeah and then you're going to coffee
shops you Lord too much like recognizing
you and just being like you're like [ __ ]
I just wanted to kind of yeah you know
and it's uh
like you're hearing Tech conversations
Tech it's the tech stuff yeah because if
if somebody listens to the podcast and
they say hi honestly there are days when
I need it like it feels good but but but
I'll paint a picture if I'm this this
like actually happened to me something
very similar to this if however I like
spot a guy in a man bun who has more
tattoos than like a Brazilian MMA
fighter who's been to prison and has
like an Ayahuasca t-shirt on and is
wearing like a Bitcoin bracelet
and comes over to me he's like yo bro
yeah
well I used to listen to your stuff but
more of a lecture yeah
that Lex Friedman who's actually a great
podcaster but somebody says this to me
and I'm like what is this interaction
about like this is such a bizarre
interaction that like archetype
which is at the Nexus of a bunch of
circles including something called
conspirituality whoever came up with
that high five one of the best words
ever but this like conspirituality that
seems to have taken as its HQ
Austin you started this drives me cuckoo
bananas I
I did not start the question no but you
were one of the first people I heard
talking about Ayahuasca and [ __ ] well
yeah that's true and then as soon as
something is as soon as something is
popular enough that people are doing it
because it's popular then I'm I'm like I
want to just exit stage left yeah I saw
this piece in the New York Post about
socialites using
Ayahuasca to do God knows what and it's
just the same status [ __ ]
the cars the good the goodies that you
show to your friends like all the status
stuff that drives me
completely nuts and look I'm sure I play
some of those games myself because we're
human and we all play some of those
games I don't know that you do like I
know well I've never seen you drive a
crazy car no do you always have shitty
cars yeah yeah I do it's true it's true
and yeah I don't in that way I don't
plan yeah of those games or I try not
and your houses have always been very
reasonable yeah yeah they're modest you
know uh you have a private jet but
that's
yeah you know aside from my fleet of
golf golf streams yeah very reasonable
so as soon as especially with the
Psychedelic stuff
God it makes me like so sad on some
level that
like the [ __ ] monkeys can't help but
like soil their own home over and over
again it's just like oh guys come on
like this one thing can we not turn this
into
like a kicking it with the Kardashians
keeping up with
whoever the hell is
your next door neighbor and uh because
like my instead of
this sort of sideways glance making sure
that someone has noticed your hot new
like Bugatti now it's like oh oh well
you had a good Shaman experience let me
tell you about my Shaman and it's like
oh it's the same jerking off it's the
same stupid game
and I've still have never done the uh
the actual Ayahuasca I gotta do that one
time with you I'd love to
yeah we can talk about it we can talk
about I mean I I know you'd give me the
authentic [ __ ] I don't want that like
[ __ ] I want to go if I'm gonna do
what's going
I'm just gonna be like hold on let me
hop on Craigslist find somebody good
give me a second casual encounters does
that make sense I don't know how they're
advertising these days
I will say just as a quick note with
with Ayahuasca specifically
I talk so many more people out of using
well this is broadly speaking out of
using psychedelics than I have ever
talked into using psychedelics I think
that's something that a lot of folks
listening may not realize
that
I'm mostly disqualify or discourage
people from doing Ayahuasca or any
psychedelic
it just depends a lot on the specifics
for me because these things are so
strong and they can be
incredibly destabilized I've been there
and after I did that high-dose mushrooms
very amazing experience and definitely
therapy like I should have done like
they tell you all compressing this
little thing but for two or three days
after I was just kind of like oh
emotions were all over the place you
know it's like it's not just smooth
sailing from the second you get done you
know the chemicals are gonna rebalance
and [ __ ] yeah and you're
you're increasing plasticity so if you
take
you just imagine that you have like this
huge
let's just say maybe not huge like
volleyball sized ball of Play-Doh and
you have to heat it to be able to shape
it and that's your brain and then you
heat it and depending on all the inputs
and stimuli positive and negative that
enter your life or that you allow to
enter your life over the subsequent
handful of days or even weeks
will shape how that dries and it's not
automatically for the better
so
long way of of saying uh definitely do
your homework this stuff has become so
popular and I'm excited about the
therapeutic potential I'm excited about
the
potential for examining
in ways that have been
effectively impossible before for a lot
of technological reasons we will begin
to ask and answer questions about the
mind and Consciousness itself that we
have not even been able to scratch the
surface of
in you know even even 20 years ago I
think I think Psychiatry is going to
fundamentally change a lot of really
core ways right I mean fundamental core
kind of redundant but you get the idea
that that some of the tectonic plates
under which Psychiatry rests currently
are going to shift very dramatically and
I'm excited about that yeah
sounds great I'm I'm speaking of which
he kind of we haven't even hit any of
our topics that we're talking about
today well let me ask you before we move
on yeah like it was going to be in line
with that but yeah we'll get there we'll
get there
now that you gave me one quarter of a
drink yeah hold on I love it I'm on a
roll I may or may not have had some
other chocolates oh that's right
I did not have that but in any case an
Ayahuasca chocolate well guys that would
be the most that would be like cat [ __ ]
sandwich this is like the flavor really
comes to mind all right why would you
want to do say Ayahuasca what would uh
what would the the poll be
potentially well I mean for me I I have
had a few experiences
on on psychedelics that every drug that
you take is a little bit different right
like you have a different door open
right like high-dose weed is going to
feel very different than high-dis
mushrooms because it's gonna feel very
different than microdosed acid which I'm
just talking about the things that I've
I've tried
so I imagine there's another door to
open there boofing ketamine different
door ketamine very different I've done
I've done ketamine before in a
therapeutic setting and it was it was it
was actually the most Pleasant like
chill thing I've ever done like it's
like just chill you know watch out for
the long-term brain damage if you guys
ever do it we'll get into that in
another episode yeah so you know for me
I'm trying to figure out and this is on
onto my first point about my my seven
day Retreat that I'm going to do wow
that was a good head fake did you answer
my question no no no what I'm saying is
that I I wanna I wanna open as many
doors as possible during this lifetime
why not you know okay all right hey it's
not to say I'm gonna go in in and stick
to one door and be down that path for
the next you know six months but why not
just try it like I'm we're gonna be dead
in 40 years it's true despite despite
all the people yeah skipping lunch and
dinner in hopes of eeking out an extra
three years so you were gonna segue
opening doors yeah and you know
the problem Tim I I have with a lot of
these compounds is that I feel like
they're very prescriptive and I worry
that you know you get these you get
these changes don't get me wrong and
granted I don't have as much data as you
do on this on this front but for me I
felt this like nice relief for like a
month you know and then it kind of
creeps back in to the normal steady
state of the things right and so the
plasticity I wonder is it like something
that you have to do multiple times and
like how many times and then then on the
on the worst case of this you hear about
these people that they just don't ever
come back and they're they're lifelong
journeyers that are they these you know
Psychonauts that and you're like are you
killing more brain cells are you really
we reworking the plastic there are you
just kind of like you know yeah or if
took that play down just like just threw
it down a sand dune exactly so for me
I've been you know I've we've mentioned
this many times on the show he's like I
I love uh the meditation side of things
I think of it as a kind of a
trying to reach the same Peak but in a
more kind of steady state like every day
a micro dose way that eventually over a
decade or longer of practice you'll
eventually get to some amazing State of
Consciousness I'm obviously not there
yet but I'm doing my first seven day
silent retreat at uh Mountain Cloud Zen
Center which I'm very excited about
senator's Place Henry's Place yeah Henry
shookman yeah nice fantastic teacher so
why do
this Retreat what are you hoping to gain
from it well if you read a lot of the
Zen books that are out there a lot of
the whether it be three pillars of Zen
or Zen the authentic gate a lot of the
big unlocks that happen with meditation
are not just through 50 minutes a day
which then is typically 25 minutes of
seated meditation five minutes of
walking and then another 25 minutes of
seated
it actually happens at these sessions of
these like proper Retreats you know
where you're doing days meditating and
you really go deep it allows your mind
to really calm and you've done this
you've been there
so I I just I just want to go
I want to see what's there like in this
Spirit of unlocking these other doors
and trying new things like hell yeah
like let's let's go let's go you know
lfg Zen
uh all right are you concerned at all do
you have any worries how your knees
gonna be
you're gonna be sitting a lot I'm gonna
be bringing my seated I use a kind of
Japanese style seated bench for for
meditation versus the folded legs kind
of like a sybian it's got a little
adapter on it yeah yeah exactly so I'm
gonna go and do that touchy magic wand
keeps the hips loose yeah exactly I
don't even know what you're saying yeah
that sounds great
I'm used to sitting for an hour a day
like that so that's that's not a I I
don't but you're gonna be going from I
know hour to how many hours I'm fine
like like it's gonna be like eight or
once you lose feeling in your legs
you're fine I'm fine I I I'm really like
I'm falling back to your room yeah I'm
all in I I just want to do this good for
you very soon yeah I do like Henry
Henry's amazing yeah for those that you
don't know just a plug for Henry through
via Sam
Henry has a lot of his courses on the
waking up app from Sam Harris so you can
you can check his stuff out there
fantastic zen teacher just a good human
you know yeah yeah great guy very well
spoken the podcast twice he's been on
twice so for people who want to taste
test of Dr shookman your second
interview with him around the cons was
just brilliant dude oh it's so good it
was fun yeah yeah because that was part
of the intention for the first episode
as you know yeah and then we got hooked
on all these other topics and didn't
come back to it and I was like all right
we need to turn around cool yeah I love
it
so
anything you've enjoyed watching
recently yes I was going to get into
some of the I figured we could do
because it's been a while since we've
hung out and I'm sure you know with
coven and everything else we've hit some
good movies yeah I was going to give you
like my favorite porn search terms five
bullet movie lists because I know you
love five bullets I actually have five
bullets right here oh my God
you love those bullets uh I do how about
my five bullet movie list and you tell
me yes or no what do you like these you
whether you've seen them oh great yeah
and then you do the same for me you got
five I do not have five I've won all
right but good good job
that's six episodes so Technic
technically
I think I have sex in you okay okay
all right so the new Top Gun [ __ ]
great fantastic can you believe that he
did all that flies I mean the the fact
that he is still doing so many of his
own stunts it's insane incredible and
it's it's makes you want to pick up
Scientology
you know you're in the right place yeah
exactly it's true the real reason that
Kevin moved to L.A that is not the case
I I thought Maverick was fantastic saw
it in IMAX I hadn't seen anything on
IMAX in a long time and I was like all
right like if we're gonna do it let's
actually do it I really went into it
being like Oh Jesus I hope they don't
ruin this you know like another Top Gun
is this gonna be cheesy and I walked
away being like damn that was good it
was really good it was fantastic and uh
and it's
there have been also a lot of filmmakers
who have enjoyed it not that that's my
indicator I just thought it'd be fun to
go see a
old school
all the tropes yeah like use all the
cliches because they were the music yeah
absolutely so good just you know exactly
what you're signing up for yeah and it's
like having something that reliable
and uplifting is I feel like really
reassuring in a world of increasingly
chaotic uncertainty it's like yeah you
know when you go to see [ __ ] Maverick
it's not going to end with like an
orphan kid dying right you know that
that's not the ending
all right so the next next movie The
the price of everything have you seen
that
price of everything is this an art dock
yes yes I saw a long time yeah I saw it
quite a few years ago yeah I really
really enjoyed it okay you've seen it
much more recently though yeah I mean it
basically just gives you if you're ever
curious uh kind of behind the scenes of
the Contemporary Art world what goes on
at auction how these artists make their
art they actually which is crazy they
actually hire like people to do the art
form some of them do yeah some of them
do it's just a crazy behind the scenes
view of the art world and for someone
that's into nfts it was just like I
learned a lot so highly recommend it it
is a wild romp through Contemporary Art
and if you're in the camp of let's just
say Advocate right you really enjoy
Contemporary Art you'll get a lot out of
it and also if if you think that much of
Contemporary Art is complete horseshit
you will also get a lot out of it
because neither Camp is going to be
disappointed yeah uh hey love can I have
a little sippers of something you find
thank you uh not a beer just like any
wine or anything thank you
so the president of the next one Elvis
the new Elvis film oh look at that there
we go bam thank you look at that bling
so the new Elvis film so here's the deal
I don't care about Elvis who cares about
Elvis right like I I didn't think no
seriously I was like Elvis old people
blah blah you watch Elvis this this new
movie why did you go to it um Tony
Conrad actually told me it was fantastic
all right and so I put it on and I was
blown away because Elvis was a misfit
like he grew up in a black neighborhood
that's how he got a lot of that kind of
Soul Vibe like that came through in his
music and then also he was like thrown
in jail because of the way he moved his
hips and [ __ ] like these were the times
back then right yeah and so like he got
on stage and like just like make his
finger move and stuff to like like get
the crowd going and [ __ ] because he
couldn't move his hips otherwise he'd be
thrown in jail it's a brilliant story
then it shows how he got hooked on drugs
and
whenever I thought of Elvis I thought of
this like kind of Vegas singer
overweight passed away oh I don't know
much about I learned a lot and
he reminds me of just any other icon I
can see why he's so massive I it was
like a history lesson in the movie so
highly recommend it yeah I'll check it
out it looked like this cinematography
was beautiful just based on the preview
fantastic yeah I was not expecting to
love an Elvis movie that is not me right
but I I walked away being like he was a
badass a lot cooler than I thought I'll
check it out yeah
um next one everything everywhere all at
once yes so good it was great and I'll
I'll give you a bit of trivia maybe if
you have not heard this already I was
watching it and
Michelle Yo's husband
from within 30 seconds I was like I know
that guy Goonies yes exactly I was like
data from The Goonies within like 30
seconds
I'm just so glad that that guy got worse
we're still around yeah I mean he could
have ended up in a million different
places and the fact that he's in he I'm
sure he's made me feel that's good too
he's been in maybe many many many other
films but to end up in this as such a I
don't want to say sleeper hip like
unexpected I would imagine Mega hit so I
I made Dario watch it and and she was
just like what the hell am I watching
it's a weird ass it's a super bizarre if
you like really weird [ __ ] and you're
just like
your jam is kind of like funky Indie odd
like it you walk away being like what
the hell did I just watch but it's it's
it's brilliant it's brilliant at the end
of the day oh yeah the jumping for the
dildo scene was just you remember that
out there trying to race oh yes yes
exactly yeah it's ridiculous yeah
there's a lot there's a lot to it it's a
strange movie so my last one on list of
ones I watched recently that was for
here's number five airplane the original
airplane
oh have you watched that recently no and
it would never get made today which is
probably part of what makes it funny
it's cringe like bad like really sexist
and there's a whole lot of jokes in
there that you look at and you're like
how the hell do they make this but it's
also like there's so many iconic moments
and and bits that when you watch it
I heard you spitting in the background
it's just it's it's fantastic to watch
again airplane yeah oldie I'm gonna do
it all right what's your one movie that
you have to recommend
well I'll share an oldie it's not as old
as airplane but if people have not seen
I recently rewatched it Spirited Away
um by Studio Ghibli which at the time
was headed up by Miyazaki Hayao
my favorite movie of all time
really yeah
it's just I watch it and I'm like I'm
good you know it just has all the
ingredients I think I also watched it
when I was 15 or 16.
it might have been a few years later but
the coming of age and hero's journey of
Chihiro who then gets renamed Sen
and there's a whole story and sequence
behind that
the fact that she goes from so weak to
so self-confident and strong
the way that is woven in
to a fantasy backdrop including so many
of my favorite things right I mean
there's like Japanese Bath House a bunch
of weird gods
you know a bunch of creepy like ghosts
type phantasms yeah like kalanasia or no
face is one of the characters
and I thought the animation and the
backgrounds and everything when you
consider particularly that they're hand
painted
was spectacular and is spectacular so
I've rewatched that I'm also very
interested now in World building I'm
doing a bunch of fiction writing right
now tell us more about that yeah yeah
we'll get into that and uh are you gonna
talk about that today or not ah no I'll
save it I'll save it but I I will say
I'm bouncing around a little bit so
Spirited Away and then recently read a
classic I think it was published in 1968
initially called The Wizard of Earthsea
by Ursula K Le Guin and it's incredible
it's such
a beautifully crafted book the language
is really not flowery but poetic
sometimes in a very simplistic way that
is to say
even very basic sentences she'll make
beautiful
and without
the wizard of Earthsea Harry Potter
doesn't exist or at least Wizarding
schools as we've come to think about
them there are so many components of
fantasy worlds we take for granted now
that would not have existed were it for
the wizard of her seat and then prior to
that
I also listened to I know I'm jumping
around a bit The Fellowship of the rank
for the first time so I had not read the
Lord of the Rings I had not read any
J.R.R Tolkien and when you consume
when you consume those two books
especially Tolkien stuff you realize how
many of the archetypes that we just
assume have been around forever because
they're so ubiquitous
came out of this guy's head
one question there did you see the new
Amazon series
the new Amazon series
I can't remember the the name of it I've
seen the trailer pop up because they're
promoting the hell out of it oh I spent
a billion dollars on the series so crazy
yeah I haven't watched yet but I will
cool and as far as my other item
my one item I'll mention it I mentioned
it to Daria earlier because I think
it's so spectacular it's a limited
series or a six part I want to say
animated series
although it it combines 3D and 2D
animation and a really Innovative
spectacular way is Arcane which you
heard me mention earlier as well and
Arcane is based on a game I have never
played but many people do League of
Legends or it's based on some characters
from this game
and riot games and there's a separate
behind the scenes series which is the
making of Arcane called Bridging the
rift which I'm also watching
and
they just threw everything at this and
the animation studio in France for teach
that helped to create the not just the
visual components there's a lot to it
and the musical is this streaming
composition behind it it is on Netflix
oh cool and every
every frame of this series could be a
beautiful large nft or a piece of
artwork that you would put on a wall I
love that I mean it is
staggeringly detailed and gorgeous
so I I'm just recommending to everybody
okay and they spent nine figures on it I
don't know if it was 100 million 200 or
more but the fact that they were willing
to dedicate after a lot of testing it
wasn't haphazard but willing to dedicate
that type of resources to a six-part
animated series oh man it's awesome it's
it's really gorgeous and it also shows a
contemporary example of World building
even though there was World building
there is World building in League of
Legends because I've learned more about
the game even though I haven't played it
when you're creating
six hours of content on a handful of
characters you have to flesh them out
and create narrative arcs that
intertwine in a way that you just don't
necessarily have to in a video game so
highest recommendation can I pick your
brain a little bit here or just maybe
get you to divulge a little bit here
you've talked you've mentioned now a
couple times about doing a little bit of
writing in this genre
you're not doing a book no but you're
doing something
I mean I think Now's the Time to start
kind of teasing things out a little bit
can you just tell us what what is Tim
working on these days like and you don't
have to go into a lot of detail but can
you can you give us a little bit of like
I'm flushing out doing this or maybe
pushing here or can you well here's what
I'll say I'll say that yeah I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna hey toasty I'm not
gonna divulge too much but I will say
that
I've been experimenting with fiction for
about
a year and a half two years well you did
the nft with with us which is great to
bring it up so my first nft experiment
thanks to your encouragement was a short
fiction piece called uh if you want to
start a war
and
I really enjoyed the process of putting
that together
and specifically the writing process of
playing with fiction and in that
particular case it was very strongly
based
on real events
it's fiction but a lot of it was based
on real people and real events which
makes it even spookier if people want to
check that out and we did that through
Grails which was great
and
I'm continuing to work those muscles
after a lot of conversations with people
like Stephen pressfield and others who
have been very encouraging
I may have some stuff to show in the
next few months cool oh yeah I'll put it
I'll put it that way but it has been a
great excuse to read
and watch
a lot of fiction
sci-fi and and fantasy primarily
and have learned so much I've ended up
going really deep so with Ursula K Le
Guin for instance it was a huge
influence on Neil Gaiman
who's writing I've Loved for a very long
time including books that I've
recommended probably on previous random
shows many years ago
like the graveyard book which is just
fantastic if people only read nonfiction
and you want an easy gateway drug
try that out the audiobook by Neil
Gaiman is fantastic in any case so I'm
I'm working as I'm thinking about
fiction through these influences and
lineages right so I'm looking at Neil
Gaiman like all sorts of aspects of his
process in writing and then I hear him
talking about Ursula K Le Guin then I go
on Twitter and ask people if I'm only
going to read one of her books which one
should I read get a whole host of
answers start with the wizard of
Earthsea that leads me somewhere else
then I watch a PBS documentary on her
life and then learn about a b and c and
just
following the breadcrumbs yeah of my
curiosity in that way has has so Tim
I've seen you a little while I've seen
you like this of a handful of times yeah
I've seen you write a handful of books
now we've been friends that long yeah
and I see when you go down rabbit holes
and I I see this I see this and I can
recognize it and it means that you're up
to something big
I'm just yeah it really does and you
look happy when you're yeah it looks
like you're having a good time having a
good time that makes me happy yeah
thanks man yeah yeah I'm excited and
it's I feel like I'm
ah I am a Awakening
muscles or
sort of creative processes that
processes that have been dormant for a
long time it feels like this is um
it's potentially a new way for you to
flex your creativity in a different way
and something that you've been it's it
sounds like this is something you've had
a passion for for a very long time
um
and now is the first time you're like
okay I'm gonna go for it here yeah
totally and it it brings back
so many and there's a value here right
it's not just simple Nostalgia there it
brings back so many emotional imprints
that were powerful and positive when I
was a kid
and especially given some of the darker
stuff that I've talked about in my
childhood it's easy for my psyche to
weigh the negative
more heavily right to weigh the dark
stuff more heavily but by say going then
into
some of these these corners of the
fiction world it's brought me back to
for instance right now I'm rereading the
never-ending story by Michael Enda I
mean which was my favorite book as a kid
and I remember I used to get in trouble
I would pull pranks and stuff and get
sent to detention and detention
in elementary school was in a few places
I always tried to dodge the nurse's
office because it's so boring I wanted
to get sent to the library and then I
would get sent to the library and I I
started reading The Neverending Story
and I fell so in love with it that I
took it out of its spot and I hid it in
a different corner of the library so
that nobody else would take it out so I
wouldn't get interrupted and then I
would get into detention again and I
would know exactly where it was hidden
so I could go back and continue reading
an evering story and
I don't know if you've ever had this
experience uh maybe you could some
people might have this experience if for
instance they saw Aladdin as a kid and
then they go and watch it as an adult
and they're like oh my God Robin
Williams had a lot of humor for adults
and I didn't notice it as a kid
similarly with a lot of these fiction
books like you read the wizard of Earth
sea or you read The Neverending Story
there is a lot of deep philosophical
discussion and
a lot of insight and you might even say
truth
that is really applicable maybe even
more so to adults who can rock that
piece of it don't you love that when you
reread something a little bit later yeah
and it just hits you in a completely
different way yeah totally it's the best
yeah it's uh it's it's a lot of fun so
I'm lit up yeah I feel good that's
awesome love to hear that
sweet
should we I've got a couple I know we're
coming up on an hour here but I've got a
couple more quick little things that are
fun I'm gonna put another hour how old
are we Jesus
it's time to go to bed it's nine it's 9
45. time to have my warm milk and go to
bed exactly put on my overalls
a little more shampers love
thank you Tim needs a little splash or
something too it's carbonated water is
great for me
so this is a fun one actually this is
completely off topic but I thought it
was just it's such a fun fact I love how
this is off topic for the random show
yeah thank you very much really
appreciate it
so one of the things that I love about
the random shows we can bring up
anything and it's just like it's like
what are we excited about what little
hacks are we finding and we used to do a
lot of that back in the day
now we're just all lazy yeah we're like
tired Max who has time for that we were
talking we joke about this before we
went live we're gonna talk about like
what cholesterol medicine we're on again
um yeah I was just saying the 20 year
old versions of us would be so
disappointed so disappointed
um
so
inflation is is is is a [ __ ] right now
right it's kind of going crazy
one of the things that it's like 34
avocado toast here in Santa Monica it's
not cheap people are hurting we got to
go tomorrow by the way I know a great
place
so one of the things that I've always
generally avoided are just bonds
government bonds and and because the
interest rates have been shed right yeah
so they have
there's something called the eye bonds
and so I bonds letter I yeah letter I
and so I bonds dumb question yeah I
bonds yeah exactly ey not the eye
so the letter i bonds
um you can buy directly on Treasury
direct.gov which is the government
website and I've done this over the last
couple of years and it's really it's
great they max out at 10K so the most
you can put in is 10 grand and you can
do it for you your spouse could have one
and then also you can do it for your
kids as well
and right now
the ibon is based on the the current
inflation plus interest on top of that
so you get
9.62 percent from the government like
that's good right and and granted that
can change with inflation and all that
but like I'll lock in that rate any day
like I'll go for that for sure so you
know I you can if you have 100 you can
do it this is applicable to pretty much
everyone right so not investment advice
but no it's totally investment advice
but if you use code kevkev yeah exactly
well the government website use code kro
and identify as a child of yeah it's one
of those things where it's like dude
when you talk about
kind of a good year in the stock market
you're talking you know 10 is what
you're kind of hoping for on average
yeah for sure and and that's with a lot
of risk right and the fact that you can
get a U.S government Bond and it's going
to yield you 9.62 right now like that's
that's just like free money so
I mean listen if the government defaults
on their bonds yes come after me yeah oh
yeah
Marauder trucks on the roads by that
point it'll be hard to find Kevin
exactly but anyway yeah this thought was
worth bringing up
clearly if I'm asking if it's I bond
with an ey I've never heard of it either
so
right there with you folks uh I got I
got two today for my kids and I'm just
gonna like put that as car money for the
future yeah just let it go and then when
it expires I'll go reinvest it and yeah
it's it's good cool I Bond I bonds with
an i well hack so I got a couple I I'm
not sure this is kind of as a hack but
I'll just I'll lump it in or include it
because it relates to thematically the
stuff that's going on in my mind and
that is I watched a master class it's a
company's Master Class they have all
these various instructionals of people
in every discipline you can imagine
including a number of I've already
mentioned like Neil Gaiman
and they had one with Amy Tan who's a
very famous novelist and the first few
segments in particular I found
incredibly compelling and she's so
eloquent also she's
she seems to speak in finished prose and
I only know a few people like that and
it always just blows my mind that
they're able to do that Sam Harris would
be another one waking up remember side
note I don't think Sam would mind me
asking
at one point I was listening to his many
meditations and I listened to one
and I texted him and I said Sam is there
any chance I could get the text for like
the X Y and Z episode he's like
what do you mean the text and I'm like
the script that you used for recording
the a b and c part of that episode and
he goes oh I don't I don't use scripts I
was like and I was like oh yeah you and
I are just different animals different
species entirely so the that's
impressive he just Wings it because it's
good content I mean he is yeah he just
has different Hardware uh and it's it's
not just a it's not born that way I
recognize it's also a skill that he's
developed but Amy Tan similar very very
well spoken and extremely good at
explaining how she approaches different
facets of fiction and how she has pulled
from her own life she also has an entire
segment where she goes through all of
the rejection letters or at least some
of the some of the most notable of the
rejection letters that she got in the
beginning just rejection after rejection
after rejection
what was cool that you don't see at
least I didn't see when I got a lot of
my rejections is
fiction editors
in a number of cases gave her great
feedback on her manuscript so they read
the whole thing and then they're like
this is
this is what you could do to improve
this part and here are three other
things you could do to really strengthen
this aspect of it you just at least in
my experience don't get that from
rejections and non-fiction so it was
cool to see not just how she thought
about responding to criticism she was
actually really grateful for a lot of
the letters but also how much she gained
from the feedback and then used to
iterate or fiction which is just
fantastic do you do the monthly on that
master class or do you do the yearly I
did neither in this particular case I
got a freebie a freebie on like Delta
Airlines or United or somewhere oh I
just keep getting billed for that [ __ ]
it drives me nuts I always think I'm
gonna like watch a bunch of them you
know and I mean I'm still paying for
match.com and because I could not figure
out how to cancel thing and it's like I
haven't used match in like 20 years so
you're welcome match.com yeah I still
get [ __ ] up
there's like two or three things I just
can't figure out how to cancel
because seriously and and you know
what's funny is they I figured it out
they only Bill you close to midnight
yeah because they know the push
notifications come through the other
night I was up late and it was like 11
30 and I had one of those pop down and
it was the year thing yeah and I'm like
you [ __ ] her and then I went to bed I
don't even know who it is I forgot but
they got me
oh you know hey that's growth hackings
for yeah exactly
[Music]
uh let's see here so physical training
I've been thinking a lot about physical
training I have you've got a gut now
dude I have a little bit of a gut geez
yeah I mean look at this look at this
[ __ ] you're you're as fat as I am
definitely I'm not are you kidding me no
you're like you're like you're like Fast
bastard for me Austin Powers let me see
it let me see
okay I'm definitely skinnier than you
dude what are you telling you won't even
oh no no let me feel that okay you're a
little skinnier
I mean look I'm so proud I'm not proud
uh and I'm not gonna blame it on age
although I guess I will say things are
slowing down that's for sure yeah uh but
I have actually lost a decent amount of
this baby fat
with a few simple things one is a sled
so I have something called the XPO
trainer
that is a mechanically
assisted or I should say mechanically
resisted sled so you don't have to load
it with plates and it's on inflatable I
think they're inflatable one may be
solid rubber tires so you can use them
on say a driveway and I've been using
the XPO trainer plus some jump rope
which is very minimal jump rope is hard
yeah I I do that for like five or ten
minutes doesn't it kill you I did jump
rope recently I was like dead afterwards
it's hard yeah yeah that's kind of the
point in the beginning so I know but
like I I thought it was going to be like
some schoolyard [ __ ] that's just
difficult oh no it's hard it's hard so
I'll do I'll do the jump rope then the
XPO trainer and then kettlebells
and I have some alternation but most
mornings I will do some combination of
those things
and I've been
doing I mean it's pretty easy for me to
do intermittent fasting so I'm just
doing late lunch early dinner typically
can we get one of those croissants in
the morning I was talking about I mean
look man I haven't seen you in what like
27 years you're on vacation yeah I mean
if I use travel as vacation equals I can
eat butter cookies anytime I want I'm
going to turn I will turn into fat
bastard from Austin Powers
which is not the look I'm going for
especially I imagine bald fat bastard
that's not good no you don't want that
no all right what else you got here
um yeah so
I think the last thing for me was that I
did one of these full body scans
what
oh yeah so oh yeah Daria is telling me
it's true I do super
no we're not cutting a video of me doing
Supernatural but I do a VR workout
called Supernatural three times a week
have you tried this I've noted you're
talking about oh my God we could have to
get Tim to do it right after this right
yes you're gonna freak out dude okay
it's really good I hate VR it's stupid
this is amazing yeah well I love that
you've been like short VR for like the
last 10 years
but you you now own a VR device yeah
well I've had a VR device you have to
play with all the latest [ __ ] if you're
a technologist yeah all right I'm just
saying that like it's dumb except for
this app this app's amazing so
Supernatural is it's a like you have two
lightsabers okay and you have to slice
it in the air and it sounds like it's
not Fruit Ninja it's like way better
than that
it's done to music it's choreographed
music it's amazing okay I mean like
lightsabers chopping things yeah
choreographed music I mean that's three
for three for me anyway Supernatural is
how I get my uh my hit in every almost
like every other day pretty much so some
more more slicing and less jump rope
yeah you'll like it we'll try more more
croissants we're gonna try it afterwards
um so that's my big thing the other
thing I was gonna say is I did one of
those full body MRI scans yeah we should
talk about this this is something I need
to get on yeah so
yeah you know what honestly it was like
I don't know if it was my mom getting
cancer I think I did it before that but
like I was just one of those things
where I got to the stage in life where I
had a couple little girls and I'm like
you know
I yeah Tia was telling me he was like
Hey you know you can do these you're at
the age now or it makes sense
see if anything shows up they can detect
like it's it's it's something like
eighty percent of cancers it's stage one
which is amazing yeah and so I was like
okay let's do it so I went and did it
two years ago came back
you know all the standard stuff like oh
we see this here but you know that's
normal like this is a little bit weird
you have an extra vertebrae which I
actually do which is weird
um so a little vestigial tail yeah
exactly a bunch of [ __ ] like that is
so uh I I do that and then I go for year
two and I go and get the scan again and
they call me up and they're they're like
yeah it turns out you have a little
brain aneurysm a little a little small
brain aneurysm and I'm like I'm like
what the [ __ ] like this is crazy okay
tell me more and then after the fact
like a month later or not a month later
but a few weeks later my doctor calls
them and says hey what do we see on the
first Scan they found it on the first
scan as well it hadn't changed which is
great yeah and it's super tiny it's the
smallest my doctor said if they hadn't
been using the latest tech they wouldn't
even have detected it at all because it
was so small so it's only one millimeter
and they don't treat them until they get
to seven millimeters yeah so it's like
it's totally fine you want to keep your
blood pressure low and all that but it's
also it's weird because in some sense
like you want to detect those stage one
cancers but there's a lot of false
positives not that this is a false
positive it's something to pay attention
to certainly changing my dietary actions
in terms of keeping sodium low and like
lowering my blood pressure yeah but it's
something you should do which is why
we're having croissants and coffee
exactly well I mean that's
I mean was that I would imagine that to
be terrifying yeah
it's 45 minutes so it's fast and they
not the procedure the review of the
results yeah I mean you go through it
and I have a couple spots on my brain
and they they told me you're allowed one
per decade and so like you're fine you
have you know two or three whatever
that's fine I'm like okay that still
doesn't sound good like don't worry it's
like a bruised Apple but that's fine
yeah and then they're like they're like
your lymph nodes this is the first scan
they're like your lymph nodes are really
swollen on the left side I'm like cool
like what does that mean and they're
like did you get your your covid vaccine
on that side I'm like yeah I did they're
like okay that's why and then that would
turn into being fine and then you know
they found like some other [ __ ] like
there's a little bit of like a a little
a little tail no there's like a little
like like I have this little tiny bulge
in my right nut sack it's just it's kind
of like the the little stringy thing
that connects to the sack kind of Bulge
out a little bit and they're like that's
totally normal it's not cancer you're
fine blah blah so like you know it's
just like
oh my God so
let me just rewind so I make sure no
just make sure I'm hearing you currently
so were you pissed that they did not
have changed yeah that they didn't spot
it first time around I think it was it
was so small that they just they have
different it's not a radiologist whoever
it is that reviews it it's probably
Radiology I think it is
I think the first part was like this is
so insignificant I don't even need to
call it out and the second one called it
out yeah they were just like and then
they compared the notes and it was fine
this is the story I haven't told
a friend of mine
went in had a scan they found a growth
in his brain non-cancerous
a decent size operated removed it he's
fine
but he didn't even know he had it and he
was just going in for for a thing and it
was growing yeah and it saved his life
most likely yeah that's that's wild and
so it's [ __ ] like that and the the
Radiologists want to talk to him he said
the number he goes I don't really drink
he goes but the number of bottles of
wine I get in the mail from people that
are like you say in my life because you
found this at stage one or stage two
I don't know it's just one of those
things where get your Diagnostics folks
and I mean do it more
hesitate to say this but like don't
don't push out the interval if you're
supposed to get something every five
years if anything get it more frequently
don't push it out I had so I have
recently had the opposite experience
with a friend of mine who went in for a
routine exam stage four cancer terminal
holy [ __ ] and I just uh spent several
days with him and
uh not have a cancer not because I don't
want to give specifics just in case
people like triangulate stuff but it's
metastasized and
at this point surgery at least some type
of surgery don't make any sense and man
if you want a proof point for
what someone can do with Decades of
meditation practice
he is
incredibly upbeat he's super happy he is
as productive as he can be he's spending
a lot of time with loved ones of course
but he is
consciously choosing of all the decision
trees
a path of
gratitude and
not naive optimism but optimism in the
sense of looking at everything as
the glass half full and
I was so inspired by this because I'm
going through some hard stuff myself and
to see someone in those circumstances
able to demonstrate that this just blew
my mind yeah and I've spent I know well
enough and we've had enough interactions
I know it is not an act it is not an act
and
I'm really impressed because that's not
automatically the case I mean there are
people including famous famous
meditators who are world famous teachers
who on their Death Beds or in the
process of going through hospice just
say over and over again to their closest
friends like I don't want to die I don't
want to die I don't want to die and
they're afraid which is understandable I
might be that person I mean certainly I
have no confidence that I would end up
responding the way my friend is
responding but it's been
incredibly inspiring wow yeah and uh I
mean it's certainly sad in its own way
but
a real gift that he's also giving those
around him
it's incredible how are you doing with
dealing with all that
uh you mean with with his situation
being a friend is having a friend go
through something like that you know
uh are you gonna see him again do you
think before he passes or is it
something I would like to I would like
to I mean it's I don't know how long the
time Horizon is it's it's uh it may not
be that long
I am
doing well with it
because of how he
is able to
choose to respond to this unfolding
story
of course it sat on a number of levels
right but I mean we're all we all have a
one-way ticket as far as we know yeah
you know my dad before he passed said
there's no lease on life he just like
wanted to remind me of that like yes
like you know it's coming for all of us
yeah yeah absolutely and it's and it's
not something you want to think about
all the time right but
if you think about it none of the time
you also have a problem and this this
has been a very strong reminder for me
it was like yeah
get it together you know like when I had
uh don't dick around too much like have
fun don't take everything seriously but
also
realize that like every moment you have
like this not to get all cheesy but it's
like these are precious
amazing moments yeah everybody's healthy
yeah I think about that with my girls
every day with the kids you know um I
had Sam Harris on the podcast a while
ago a couple years ago and we talked
about the
Buddhist monk that was sitting in a
meditative pose on the cover of Rage
Against the Machine that doused himself
in gasoline
in defiance of local government and lit
himself on fire and did not flinch and
this has been recorded yeah and there
was pictures and everything else
did not move yeah holy [ __ ] you want to
talk about meditation really working
like oh my God
yeah yeah I can't do that
I could barely stand a cold plunge this
morning for three minutes
so yeah I was in the song today I'm like
oh 15 minutes ago I made 20 okay we'll
even go for it
yeah yeah I mean it's uh
you know all these things are kind of
pointing at
by all these things I guess I'm
bookending some of our earlier
discussion that touched on psychedelics
and I mentioned Psychiatry and these
tectonic plate shifts that I think are
are currently underway but will be most
noticeable
five ten years from now
and the types of Feats that we're
describing
all point to severe
I think under appreciation
for what we are capable of in terms of
shaping
mind and Consciousness yeah
right because lighting yourself on fire
and not flinching should not be possible
no like I'm not yeah clearly not even
David yeah no one wants to end up having
to test that right but
there are a lot of outcomes that we're
seeing say in treating various
diagnoses related to I don't want to say
Mental Illness but psychiatric
conditions that are considered
intractable or extremely difficult to
treat and some of the outcomes that
we're seeing which are not solely
produced through psychedelics I don't
want to make psychedelics not like
Panacea of any type they're not they
have in some cases very significant
risks
but it's it's clear that many of the
paradigms
through which we've treated patients
specifically with any type of what we
would consider mental illness
is is likely resting on a number of
assumptions that are completely untrue
yeah and that's exciting it's really
exciting I remember our friend Dr Weil
20 years ago was speaking about
chemotherapy and said how barbaric it
will look
in the future and it turns out that it's
actually true we have immunotherapy now
my mom's going through it like there's a
lot of these things that are very very
promising and we're just like a few
years away from some really exciting
breakthroughs I'm not sure if you saw
that that New York Times article about
the uh it was like eight out of eight
patients cured with this new type of
immunotherapy and cancer did you see
that was a groundbreaking crazy study
about this new type of immunotherapy
that's just now coming out here soon but
I'd imagine the same is true for
psychedelics right like you know 20
years from now they've honed it in and
figured out the right
dose the right I mean they may even
modify those molecules like who knows
where it's going to go but it's going to
be exciting it is going to be exciting I
I think the
you know we're all driven by
our beliefs right these thoughts we take
to be true
and assumptions
even
scientists are subject to this right I
mean scientists are not robots and so
you have
anyone doing anything comes in with a
certain set of
of
biases or biases and
in psychedelics you see also in the in
the Psychedelic for-profit sector you
see a lot of motivated reasoning where
you you have a number of split camps and
different kind of schisms Within These
communities and one of them
is between Camp a and Camp a believes
that many of the clinical outcomes for
depression and PTSD and so on are driven
by the content of an experience
and the narrative that you can
restructure After You observe It For the
First Time perhaps right the software
that's that's behind many of your
decisions blah blah blah blah they think
it's the content in which case if that
is your belief and in an Ideal World
you'll be able to test these things
definitively and many people are
making attempts at this but it's it's
really challenging then you want enough
workspace to allow all that to play out
so let's just say
psilocybin and having a session of four
to six hours would be viewed as a
feature and not a bug
then you have Camp B which is saying oh
yeah all those hallucinations terrible
side effects
really what's happening is on this
structural level and this type of XYZ is
happening to this receptor we can do all
that
if we change the molecule without the
Psychedelic effects and also press it
into like a 30-minute session and that
will copy and paste into our current
Medical
formatting much more easily but there's
a profit motive there right because if
you if you can scale something in that
way
and reduce some of the quote-unquote
side effects and also patent it yeah and
absolutely panned it and then also make
it a drug that you need to take at least
twice a week or maybe even every day
instead of once a month or once every
three months
that there aren't really a bad thing
though it's not automatically a bad
thing but I just think it's important
for folks to be aware of incentives and
to track incentives right so
because then just turns into another a
better antidepressant which is not
necessarily a bad thing it's not
necessarily A Bad Thing it depends on
how the antidepressant is achieving its
effects right and there are
immediate
there are immediate changes that can be
beneficial in a whole host of different
situations with medicine generally
speaking right so with the
pharmacological intervention it's like
if you're if you're bleeding out and you
need a coagulant like you don't want the
you don't have to wait a long time for
that to work and similarly it's like if
you are suffering from
suicidal ideation and are at risk of
harming or killing yourself you need
something that's going to work really
quickly in which case
just putting this out there as like
intravenous ketamine treatment maybe
it's the number one thing right maybe
maybe something you consider
it's not going to fix all of your
problems but it's going to stop the
immediate bleeding so to speak isn't
that what they do if someone comes in
and they're about to commit suicide
don't they give them IV ketamine like
I've heard that's a thing I don't know
what it looks like actually I'd love to
hear from people in the audience who who
know how something like that is triaged
in an ER right if somebody shows up and
maybe a loved one brought them and
they're like I'm gonna blow my head off
uh I would I mean I would have to
imagine there's like sedation maybe they
use some hypnotics they might use
ketamine I don't know but in a I had
heard that once
I do know I know a number of people who
were on the verge of blowing their heads
off who with competent supervised
uh Academy and assisted therapy
I mean literally within one or two
sessions we're able to say I don't know
what I was so upset about like I can't
even believe I was so wound up about
that
and that's incredible it's not a
indefinite fix
But to answer your question to come back
like there are cases in which I think it
makes sense to have some type of
Maintenance dose right so let's just say
you're able to strip out a bunch of the
hallucinogenic or psychedelic effects
from LSD and it remains incredibly
effective for cluster headaches which is
actually one indication
and the best combination of effect
and minimizing side effects is to have
like some small dose four or five days a
week great fantastic but if you're
trying to process
or contend with some type of childhood
trauma that has been plaguing your
automatic behaviors and maybe addictions
perhaps you know self
destructive or otherwise destructive
behaviors then I don't know if what we
need is
a maintenance drug there may be more
psychological surgery required for that
in which case perhaps the content does
play a meaningful role I happen to
believe that's the case in in many
instances but
10 years from now yes psychedelics is
going to be crazy because it
it's
subject to these Market forces and these
incentives
so you know don't ask a barber if you
need a haircut kind of situation
if you go to an orthopedic surgeon and
you're like do I need surgery they're
not all going to say you need surgery
but they have a certain incentive
to do surgeries
as realizing that in advance is
important
but I I do think what we will find
through the study of psychedelics is
even if psychedelics as compounds were
to disappear 10 years from now let's
just say let's just say they go back to
being they are reclassified
rescheduled right and then all over the
place and then who knows like some
senator's kid jumps off a balcony and
then the whole thing goes kaput and it's
thrown back into psychedelic scientific
winter
even if that's the case within the next
10 to 15 years I think we will learn so
many new things about the functioning of
the mind and processing of trauma
metabolizing of difficult experience and
issues such as
treatment resistant depression complex
PTSD that the treatment paradigms will
shift even if the compounds
disappear which I don't think they will
and I also think there are so many
indications that do not require high
doses of psychedelics which will be well
treated with lower doses of psychedelics
so I'm excited to see what bears out
yeah absolutely yeah
awesome anything else you want to cover
[Music]
I think that's it for me yeah
I'm I'm good as well that was awesome
yeah good to see you brother yeah good
to see you too man thanks for thanks for
having me over for dinner yeah sitting
on our our couch here Mr Toast is in the
background for those watching the
audience yeah 12 and doing well yeah
passed out so you know not that long
while it is I mean it is long ago not in
like historical
uh evolutionary terms but in like our
lifetime terms a while ago like we had
we had a shot very much like this in San
Francisco in one of your I don't know I
don't say first Apartments but
earlier apartments with a couch like
this and toasts
walked by as a puppy and chewed through
one of these XLR cables totally back
then I had a little bit of hair
that's right I think I knew crazy that
you had a hair back then yeah it's weird
it's weird somebody was asking me
they're like yeah but you could probably
figure out how to regrow hair and I'm
like yeah but if I just suddenly like
disappeared for six months and then
reappeared with like a huge mop on my
head
I mean that's what Elon Musk did you see
the early Elon Musk pictures yeah yeah
you could do it I could do it but I a I
don't I don't feel the need be I just
think especially from my friends I would
get so much endless [ __ ] do you think
you should do it right now she said no
no no no
yeah it's Tim Tim yeah no Mr Clean I've
grown into the Mr Clean look I'm good
I'm good with it
uh all right brother all right we'll do
this again in a few months yeah for sure
yeah see more of each other in person
all right peace peace